Since the general pattern continues to hold after conditioning on
each of the buckets of year joined, we might increase our
confidence that this observation isn't just an artifact of the
time users have had to accumulate friends. Let's look at this
relationship in another way. We could also look at tenure
and friend count as a rate instead. For example, we could
see how many friends does a user have for each
day since they've started using the service. Let's see if you
can create a summary of this rate, that shows how many friends a user
has for each day since the user started using Facebook. Subset the data so
you only consider users with at least one day of tenure. Once you have
that summary answer these two questions. What's
the median rate? And, what's the maximum rate?